[Musik] der Adel lebt in der bunten
und dem goldenen Blatt der Adel lebt
und in der Gegend
der Adel pinkelt
Ernst August von H der Adel hat Disziplin [Musik]
eigentlich nur die Queen der
Adel singt von der Balustrade
schöner [Musik]
wohnen er den Generationen der Adel schnackselt
nur mit Adele die Folgen sieht man ja
schlabberlippe der Habsburger die Löffel von
Prinz Charles der Adel gründet Stiftung das
tut dem allgut der Adel der hat ganz altes
Geld und ein Adressbuch aus blue der Adler
hat Hunde die stöbern unser Portier
die liegen dann nach der Treibjagd
Mathe dann kam mir nie ich hätte sogar
einen Mörder aus alter Mörder dann wäre ich
Jade liegt ich würde in meinem Schloss
Park einen ginkgo-pflanzen wird Wiener
Walzer tanzen mein Blatt ist blue ich [Musik]
trüge ich wäre gerne von ich wär gern zu
der Adel bekleckert sich eigenen [Musik]
regionale Gerichte Zapfen von der eigenen
Fichte Spargel von der eigenen Scholle
mit Schinken oder Scholle der Erde kauft
sich den Osten zurück denn er war vorher da
der schützt die Umwelt denn sie gehört die mir die
Gräfin Tatjana Luise Benedikt ab Pia von Zuschauer
hat auf dem Sekretär ein Bild von
dem kleinen Laurin Vincent Alexander
karl-theoan Jakob pandolf Kaspar
Melchior Eberhard glad Dracula von zusch
ippe [Musik]
Demokratie ist nur eine vorübergehende [Musik]
ich hätte sogar einen Mörder
außer Alter Marder dann wäre ich
malte meine Töchter in altem Öl sitzt still Isabel
weil dein Stammbaum das jetzt will ein schönes
Gefühl [Musik] bei Whatsapp oder lasse Scheiben
[Musik] adelig eine calasse für mich [Musik] danke